So what are we going to make of television anyway? I think the most interesting idea you hear about television right now is this idea that right now-- all of us-- we are living through the golden age of television, that this is the kind of golden age that people are going to look back on years from now, the way we look back on the '20s and '30s as the heyday of jazz, or the '70s as the heyday for a certain kind of movie.
所以，我们到底该如何看待电视呢？我觉得现在关于电视最有趣的观点是：我们所有人正生活在电视的黄金时代。人们多年后回首这段时期，会像我们回望20年代和30年代的爵士乐全盛时期，或70年代的某种电影巅峰期那样，将这段时期视为黄金时代。
What's exciting is that the conventions of TV seemed to be changing all the time and expanding.
令人兴奋的是，电视的惯例似乎一直在改变和扩展。
That's J.J. Abrams, one of the creators of Lost , and Alias , and Felicity . And he says the same thing that lots of people in TV say, that because network television audiences go down every year-- because of the Internet, because of video games, because of competition from cable-- what we have is a situation where the big networks are scrambling to keep audiences. And then there are dozens of cable channels that are competing for those audiences, which has led to this period of incredible experimentation.
那是J.J.艾布拉姆斯（J.J. Abrams），《迷失》（Lost）、《双面女间谍》（Alias）和《大学生费莉希蒂》（Felicity）的创作者之一。他说出了电视界许多人的共鸣：由于互联网、电子游戏以及有线电视竞争的影响，电视网的收视率连年下滑，各大电视网为了留住观众正竭尽全力，而几十个有线电视频道也在争夺这些观众，这导致了这一时期出现了令人难以置信的实验性创新。
Networks realize in the increasing, desperate need to grab an audience, that they need to do things that stand out, that are unique, that are different, stories and series that will generate discussion.
各大电视网意识到，在日益迫切地吸引观众的需求下，他们需要做出脱颖而出、独特、与众不同的东西，创作出能引发讨论的故事和系列剧。
And so there is this climate where people are just trying different stuff. And as a result, in any given week there are probably at least two great shows on the air. And then another bunch of shows that are just kind of interesting. So you've got The Daily Show , and The Office , and Friday Night Lights , and South Park , and Intervention , and Project Runway and 30 Rock -- just a lot of interesting stuff out there.
因此，在这种环境下，人们开始尝试各种不同的事物。结果就是，在任何一个星期，电视上可能至少有两部出色的节目，还有一批同样有趣的节目。比如《每日秀》（The Daily Show）、《办公室》（The Office）、《胜利之光》（Friday Night Lights）、《南方公园》（South Park）、《狂乱救星》（Intervention）、《天桥风云》（Project Runway）和《我为喜剧狂》（30 Rock）——外面真的有很多有趣的内容。
Though of course, not everybody feels that TV is so great. When the television version of our radio show first premiered in 2007, we took our show on a six-city tour-- to Boston, New York, Minneapolis, Chicago, Seattle, and Los Angeles. And when I would mention to the crowd that we, ourselves, had just finished shooting a television show, it sometimes got a little chilly. In Minneapolis, a guy actually yelled, "Judas."
当然，并不是每个人都觉得电视那么好。2007年，当我们的广播节目电视版首播时，我们在六个城市进行了巡演——波士顿、纽约、明尼阿波利斯、芝加哥、西雅图和洛杉矶。当我向观众提到我们自己刚拍完一部电视节目时，气氛有时会变得有点冷淡。在明尼阿波利斯，甚至有人冲我喊道：“犹大。”
There are a lot of people who think that television is terrible, that it's bad for kids, it's bad for American politics, it's the cause of all kinds of problems in this country. And so, with this disagreement all around us, we decided to tackle the subject head on. Television is at the center of our culture. It's hard to avoid. What does it do to us anyway?
有很多人认为电视很糟糕，对孩子不好，对美国政治有害，是导致国内各种问题的根源。因此，面对我们周围的这种分歧，我们决定正面探讨这个话题。电视处于我们文化的核心，很难避开。它到底对我们做了什么？
Well, from WBEZ Chicago it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Our show today-- on this weekend when we begin the second season of our television show-- What We Learned from Television. Our show was recorded in front of live audiences on the six-city tour in 2007. Our show in four acts-- Act One, 29. David Rackoff-- like a wild child raised in the woods, a foreigner to our people-- tries TV for the first time since he was a child. Act Two, Turkeys in Pilgrim Clothing, Sarah Vowell examines what happens when TV takes on a project it really has no business taking on at all. Act Three, Radio on the TV. In that act, a few words about what I've personally learned about television during the first year in which I worked on a television show myself. Act Four, My Other Dog's a German Shepherd. In that act, Dan Savage-- a syndicated sex-columnist and podcaster who is not put off by dirty content-- finds something so filthy, so weird, and perverted on television that he doesn't want his son to watch it. And it's a kid's show made for children. On our six-city tour, we were lucky enough to travel with a band that we love, the Mates of State-- Kori Gardner and Jason Hammel. So you'll be hearing from them too. Stay with us.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》（This American Life），由公共广播国际公司（PRI）发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。今天我们的节目——在这个开启我们电视节目第二季的周末——主题是“我们从电视中学到了什么”。我们的节目是2007年在六个城市的巡演中录制的，在现场观众面前进行。节目分四幕：第一幕，《29》。大卫·拉科夫（David Rakoff）——就像一个在森林里长大的野孩子，我们人民中的一个异乡人——自孩童以来第一次尝试看电视。第二幕，《朝圣者装束的火鸡》，莎拉·沃威尔（Sarah Vowell）审视了当电视承担起它根本不该触碰的项目时会发生什么。第三幕，《电视上的广播》。这一幕讲一些我个人在参与制作电视节目的第一年里对电视的看法。第四幕，《我的另一条狗是德国牧羊犬》。在这一幕中，丹·萨维奇（Dan Savage）——一位联合辛迪加的性专栏作家和播客主，从不因内容肮脏而退缩——在电视上发现了一些如此肮脏、怪异和变态的内容，以至于他不想让儿子看。而那竟然是一档为儿童制作的儿童节目。在六个城市的巡演中，我们有幸与我们喜爱的乐队Mates of State（科里·加德纳和杰森·哈梅尔）同行。所以你也会听到他们的声音。请继续收听。
Act One, 29. We were curious how somebody who hasn't seen TV in a while would react to the cornucopia of stuff that is on today. And so we turned to David Rakoff. David Rakoff pretty much stopped watching television when he got out of college 20 years ago. We asked him to watch 29 hours-- any channels, any shows-- and tell us his impressions. We chose 29 hours because that is the amount the average American watches in one week. [AUDIENCE GASP]
第一幕，《29》。我们很好奇，一个很久没看电视的人会对当今电视上琳琅满目的节目作何反应。于是我们找到了大卫·拉科夫。大卫·拉科夫在20年前大学毕业后就基本不看电视了。我们请他观看29小时——任何频道、任何节目——并告诉我们他的印象。之所以选择29小时，是因为这是美国人平均每周观看电视的时长。[观众倒吸一口凉气]
Do you guys not live in the United States of America? [AUDIENCE LAUGHTER] You literally gasped. David has this report.
你们难道不住在美国吗？[观众笑声] 你们刚才真的倒吸了一口气。大卫带来了这份报告。
Television and I broke up a long time ago. Before this assignment, it would have taken me at least four months to watch 29 hours of TV. I know how that sounds-- smarmy, superior, like one of those people who looks down on others for watching television and says things like, "Well, I enjoy Nova ."
我和电视很久以前就分手了。在这次任务之前，我至少需要四个月才能看完29小时的电视。我知道听起来怎么样——虚伪、傲慢，就像那些瞧不起看电视的人，还会说诸如“哦，我只喜欢看《新星》（Nova）”之类的话。
It's not that I'm above the medium. It's that I can't be trusted around television. Watching television was forbidden when I was a child, a tactic which anyone knows only results in raising an addict. When my parents weren't around, I secretly watched it all. I had no standards, no filter. I loved everything. These days my set lives in the closet. Yeah, the cheap metaphor of that isn't lost on me. Television is my secret shame. And that was fine with me until Alex Blumberg-- my producer from This American Life -- called and offered to set me up with cable for this story.
并不是我高看了这一媒介，而是电视对我而言太危险。小时候家里禁止看电视，任何人都知道这种策略只会培养出一个瘾君子。当父母不在时，我偷偷看了一切。我没有标准，没有过滤，什么都喜欢。如今，我的电视机被锁在壁橱里。是的，这个廉价的隐喻我当然明白。电视是我心底的耻辱。而在《美国生活》的制片人亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）打电话给我，提出要为我装上有限电视做这个报道之前，我一直觉得没问题。
My friends were a little too excited about the news. When I tell Jodi that I'm getting cable, she is as thrilled as if I'd told her I'd just fallen in love. "Thank God," she says, "Now we'll have something to talk about."
朋友们对这个消息表现得有点太兴奋了。当我告诉乔迪（Jodi）我要装有线电视时，她激动得好像我刚告诉她我坠入爱河一样。“谢天谢地，”她说，“现在我们终于有共同话题了。”
Had I really been such terrible company? I know, of course I was. I am terrible company. I can be a joyless, little rain cloud of a thing. But was I terrible company because I didn't have cable? Does that explain everything that is wrong with me? All the therapy, the brief experimentation with serotonin reuptake inhibitors, all that money thrown away, when all the while help lay on the other end of an 800 number at Time Warner Cable.
我真的有那么难相处吗？我知道，当然是这样。我确实很难相处。我可以是个毫无乐趣的、小小的乌云。但我是因为没装有线电视才难相处的吗？这能解释我身上所有的问题吗？所有的心理咨询，短暂尝试服用血清素再摄取抑制剂，所有浪费的金钱，原来救赎一直躺在时代华纳有线电视公司（Time Warner Cable）800电话的另一端。
The installation guy arrives and sets me up. And I gingerly settle into my new life as a Nielsen family of one. Things don't begin well. I go looking for Project Runway and find instead that the channel has been taken over by a show called The Real Housewives of Orange County. It's an all-day marathon. And yet, nothing happens. It is like watching paint dry-- stupid, shallow, fake-breasted, Republican paint.
安装人员来了，帮我装好了。我小心翼翼地开始了作为“尼尔森家庭”成员之一的新生活。事情开始得并不顺利。我想找《天桥风云》，结果发现该频道被一个叫《橘郡主妇》（The Real Housewives of Orange County）的节目霸占了。那是全天马拉松式播放。然而，什么也没发生。这就像看油漆变干一样——愚蠢、肤浅、隆胸的、共和党色彩的油漆。
It seems that in the intervening years of TV-lessness I've gotten the monkey off of my back a little bit too well. I can't keep the housewives on for longer than eight minutes before I have to turn it off. And for the next few days, I do anything but watch television. That's right. I procrastinate from watching television. I bake bread-- three loaves. I clean my apartment. I make meals and take them to sick people. I even write. I am procrastinating from TV by doing my job.
看来在我不看电视的这些年里，我已经把电视瘾戒得太彻底了。我坚持不了八分钟就得关掉。接下来的几天，我除了看电视什么都做。没错。我为了逃避看电视而拖延。我烤面包——烤了三条。我打扫公寓。我做饭送给生病的人。我甚至写作。我通过工作来拖延看电视。
Alex, my producer, calls about a week later to see how it's all going. He can hear the suspicious lack of television in the background. "Aren't you supposed to be working?" he asks.
大约一周后，我的制片人亚历克斯打电话来询问进展。他能从背景中察觉到电视的缺失。“你不应该在工作吗？”他问。
I tell him, "I don't want to be that curmudgeonly guy inveighing against the kids with their rock and roll music, but I'm appalled by what I've seen so far. He listens patiently to my Rip Van Winkle just-up-from-his-nap jeremiad explaining how I've missed the reality TV moment, how my muscles of appreciation for the form aren't developed. He talks me down. And even as he is doing so, I know how ridiculous I am being. Who needs to be talked down from watching TV? I get over myself, and I wade back in and actually watch entire programs.
我告诉他：“我不想做一个对着年轻人和摇滚乐抱怨的顽固老头，但我对目前所见感到震惊。”他耐心地听着我那刚睡醒般的长篇大论，解释我是如何错过了真人秀时代，以及我对这种形式的欣赏能力是如何未得到开发的。他开导了我。就在他开导我的时候，我也知道自己有多荒谬。谁还需要被开导着去看电视呢？我克服了自我，又涉足进去，真正看完了完整的节目。
I even enjoy some of the things I see, enjoy them immensely. Kyra Sedgwick is amazing on The Closer , and Lisa Kudrow's almost unendurable humiliation in The Comeback-- to name just two. I would drink Jon Stewart's bath water. And Channel 93-- New York City public access-- is nothing but a mesmerizing, silent traffic camera at the corner of Canal Street and the West Side Highway. It is as pretty as waves. I would happily fill out the rest of my quota watching just this. Do I sound like Bambi sniffing a flower? Well, my TV forest is suddenly new and filled with wonder and discovery.
我甚至喜欢上了一些节目，非常喜欢。《罪案终结》（The Closer）里的凯拉·塞吉维克（Kyra Sedgwick）棒极了，还有《归来记》（The Comeback）中丽莎·库卓（Lisa Kudrow）令人无法忍受的羞辱感——仅举两例。我愿意喝掉乔恩·斯图尔特（Jon Stewart）的洗澡水。还有93频道——纽约市公共频道——除了是一个迷人的、静止的交通摄像头，拍摄着运河街和西侧高速公路交叉口，什么都没有。它像波浪一样美丽。我很乐意用剩下的时间只看这个。我听起来像个闻着花香的小鹿斑比吗？好吧，我的电视森林突然变得焕然一新，充满了奇迹和发现。
I stumble upon an Evangelical channel called, Pray. And hallelujah, they are showing All About Eve , a movie I love and know virtually by heart. It seems an odd choice for an Evangelical channel. The characters all swill gin, sleep around, and work in the theater. And I feel safe in saying that of all the prayers out there in the ether that the Pray channel most hopes to answer, those of an aging, Jewish, homosexual movie buff in New York City trolling around for something to watch on TV aren't really high on that list.
我偶然发现了一个叫“祷告”（Pray）的福音频道。哈利路亚，他们正在放《彗星美人》（All About Eve），一部我深爱且几乎烂熟于心的电影。对于福音频道来说，这似乎是一个奇怪的选择。角色们都在酗酒、滥交、在剧院工作。我可以肯定地说，在以太网中所有“祷告”频道最希望能回应的祈祷中，一个在纽约市四处游荡、寻找电视看的老年犹太同性恋电影爱好者的需求，绝不在清单的前列。
It also doesn't sit very well with Alex, who calls the next week. When I proudly tell him that I've upped my tally to eight hours, he seems unimpressed, pointing out that I am two weeks and 21 hours behind schedule. And in fact, he docks me two hours, saying that a movie I've seen over 30 times doesn't count. Homophobe.
这在亚历克斯那里也行不通，他下周又打了电话。当我自豪地告诉他我把记录提升到了八小时时，他似乎并不为所动，指出我落后了进度两周、21个小时。事实上，他还扣了我两个小时，说我看了30遍的电影不算数。恐同症。
The purpose of the exercise, it seems, is to watch television. Well, I can't do that. Clearly I need a guide through this underworld, someone who truly loves the medium. I call up Jodi and I invite her over. I will cook her supper in exchange for some patient instruction. Jodi has been one of my closest friends for 12 years. But suddenly, I am as awkward as a schoolboy.
看来这项任务的目的就是看电视。好吧，我做不到。显然，我需要一个向导带我走出这个地下世界，一个真正热爱这一媒介的人。我打电话给乔迪邀请她过来。我会给她做晚餐，换取她耐心的指导。乔迪是我12年来最亲密的朋友之一。但突然间，我变得像个小学生一样尴尬。
OK, so should we eat supper at the table? Or should we eat supper in front of the television set? Is there good TV on now? Because it's only about 6:40.
好的，那我们是在桌上吃晚饭，还是在电视机前吃？现在有好看的电视吗？因为现在才6点40分。
I feel like we're about to have sex. It's not that complicated. We're just watching TV.
我觉得我们要发生关系了。没那么复杂。我们只是在看电视。
Things begin pleasantly enough. We bop around the dial happily for a while, eventually landing on an MTV program called My Super Sweet 16 . I get into the spirit at first. But for a reality virgin like myself, I'm in over my head in short order-- the callow, young sailor on shore leave looking for some tenderness who suddenly finds himself handcuffed to the bed. This particular episode of My Super Sweet 16 stars a bumptious blond from Tennessee. They might as well call the show, My Last Birthday Before Rehab .
事情开始得很愉快。我们愉快地换了会儿台，最终定格在MTV的一个叫《我的超级16岁》（My Super Sweet 16）的节目上。起初我进入了状态。但对于我这种真人秀处男来说，我很快就招架不住了——就像一个在岸上寻求温柔、却突然发现自己被铐在床上的年轻水手。这一集的《我的超级16岁》主角是一个来自田纳西州的自负金发女郎。他们完全可以把这个节目叫作《戒毒所前的最后一个生日》。
She seems an improbable 16, certainly not 16 earth-years because she looks, frankly, 35. A hard 35. A two ex-husbands, pack a day of Merits, trying her hand at real estate, sun-damaged kind of opening-your-robe-for-the-grocery-delivery-boys 35. Do you get the picture? When we meet her, she is behind the wheel of a stretch Humvee, which costs upwards of $100,000. She'd like it for her very own, and indicates this desire to her thuggish, hairy-knuckled father, just the first in what will surely be a series of men during her lifetime she will refer to as "Daddy."
她看起来不太像16岁，当然不是地球年的16岁，因为坦率地说，她看起来像35岁。那种饱经风霜的35岁。离过两次婚、一天一包Merits烟、试水房地产、被阳光晒伤、给送货小哥开门时敞开长袍的那种35岁。你明白画面感吗？当我们见到她时，她正坐在一辆价值超过10万美元的加长悍马驾驶座上。她想要这辆车，并向她那粗鲁、指关节长满毛的父亲表达了渴望，这只是她一生中将称之为“爸爸”的一系列男人中的第一个。
I looked over at Jodi , and she's having a great time, whereas I want to tear my eyes from my head and soak them in lye.
我看向乔迪，她玩得很开心，而我却想把眼睛挖出来泡在碱液里。
"Why do you always add this weird layer to things?" she asks me. "Doesn't it just remind you of when you were 16?" I am going to the bad place, as is my wont. Jodi reaches for the remote and dials it down a bit. We end up watching the TV equivalent of the vanilla, missionary position-- America's Funniest Home Videos .
“你为什么总是给事情加上这种奇怪的一层？”她问我，“这难道不让你想起你16岁的时候吗？”我正按习惯走向阴暗面。乔迪伸手去拿遥控器，调低了音量。我们最后看了电视版的“传教士姿势”——《美国家庭滑稽录像》（America's Funniest Home Videos）。
Oh.
哦。
Why do they both have sunglasses? Oh. Disaster.
为什么他们都戴着墨镜？哦。灾难。
What was she thinking?
她在想什么？
I am completely embarrassed to admit how incapacitated I am by the home movies of beloved grandmothers falling out of chairs or toddler after toddler bringing entire Christmas trees down upon themselves. Oh and look at the kitty cat open a cereal box. I am on my sofa laughing like an idiot.
我完全尴尬地承认，我竟然被这些家庭录像所击倒——看着挚爱的祖母从椅子上摔下来，或者幼儿一个接一个地把整个圣诞树拉倒在自己身上。哦，看那只小猫打开谷物盒子。我躺在沙发上像个白痴一样笑着。
See? Oh, look at the excitement you have on your face. You love America's Funniest Home Videos . You should have been introduced to this a week ago.
看吧？哦，看你脸上那兴奋的表情。你喜欢《美国家庭滑稽录像》。你早该一周前就接触这个了。
This is the worst night of my life.
这是我一生中最糟糕的夜晚。
Why? You're laughing and you're enjoying yourself.
为什么？你在笑，你在享受。
Don't you feel--
难道你不觉得——
Look, there are tears coming out of your eyes. Embrace it. Don't be afraid. You're trying to act like you weren't just having fun. There are tears on your face. I've never seen you laugh so hard.
看，你的眼泪都出来了。拥抱它吧。别害怕。你一直在装模作样，好像刚才没有玩得很开心一样。你脸上都是泪水。我从没见过你笑得这么厉害。
Don't you feel like taking a shower after all of this?
看完了这些，难道你不觉得想去洗个澡吗？
See? It goes back to me feeling like we're going to have sex. No. This is fine. What's wrong with enjoying that?
你看吧？又回到那种感觉，好像我们要发生关系了。不。这很好。享受这些有什么错？
She's right. Why can't I just let myself enjoy it? Part of it is that denying pleasure is my middle name. But Jodi feels that I'm trying to be above it all, that I'm judging her. After all, she spends time at home in front of the television, sometimes with a glass of wine even, just as we're doing. But there is a seminal difference between Jodi and myself. When she watches TV at home, alone with a drink, she has a husband in the next room. When I watch television, I am by myself. Watching TV, for me, is a referendum on my loneliness. Having the television on just seems like some desperate simulacrum of company, stuffing the other side of the bed with clothes. It is a chilly reality, brought home to me-- with all the force of a frying pan to the face-- by a small item in the New York Times on Sunday the 18th of February.
她是对的。我为什么不能让自己享受它呢？部分原因是拒绝快乐是我的中间名。但乔迪觉得我是想表现得高人一等，觉得我在评判她。毕竟，她有时会在家一边看电视，甚至喝杯酒，就像我们现在做的那样。但乔迪和我之间有一个本质的区别。当她独自一人带着酒看电视时，她的丈夫在隔壁房间。当我看电视时，我是孤身一人。对我来说，看电视是对我孤独感的一次公投。把电视打开，似乎只是一种绝望的陪伴模仿，用衣服塞满床的另一边。这是一个冰冷的现实，被2月18日周日《纽约时报》的一则小消息，以平底锅砸在脸上的力度带回给我。
The article was about how a man, a 70-year-old widower named Vincenzo Ricardo was found in his home, dead. Officials believed that Mr. Ricardo-- discovered sitting in his chair-- had been dead for more than a year. He was very well preserved, mummified, by the hot dry air in his home. Air, no doubt made even hotter and drier by the fact that for the entire year plus that Mr. Vincenzo sat stiff and expired in his recliner, his television was on.
文章讲述了一个名叫文森佐·里卡多（Vincenzo Ricardo）的70岁鳏夫在他家中被发现死亡的故事。官方认为，这名坐在椅子上的里卡多先生已经死了超过一年。由于家中空气又热又干，他的尸体保存得非常好，变成了木乃伊。毫无疑问，空气变得更热、更干燥的原因是，在里卡多先生僵硬地死在躺椅上的整整一年多时间里，他的电视一直开着。
There was apparently a study recently that showed that people who watch episodic television-- following a set of characters on an ongoing basis-- experienced many of the same positive effects that people derive from having friends, actual friends. TV is a friend, one might conclude. Well, call me old-fashioned, but the minimum of true friendship strikes me as being-- at the very least-- the capacity for one friend to look over at another and be able to say, hey buddy, how are you doing? Do you want me to call 911 or something? Because you're looking a little-- oh, I don't know-- dead.
最近似乎有一项研究表明，观看系列剧——即持续跟踪一组角色——的人，与拥有朋友、现实中的朋友的人，体验到了许多同样的积极效果。人们可能会得出结论，电视就是朋友。好吧，说我老派也好，但真正的友谊最起码应该包含这种能力：朋友能看向对方并说：“嘿，伙计，你怎么样？要我打911吗？因为你看起有点——哦，我不知道——死掉了。”
I suppose I would just rather be authentically alone than wait around in vain for Jennifer Garner to come over and give me the Heimlich maneuver. My producer, Alex, thought that was too negative a note on which to end this story, that there needed to be some moment of uplift, some edifying public radio insight. Alex suggested that what I've learned from this experience is that it is not TV that I hate so much as the fellow watching it, that I won't truly love television until I love myself. Perhaps he is right. I canceled the cable.
我想，比起徒劳地等待詹妮弗·加纳（Jennifer Garner）过来给我做海姆立克急救，我宁愿真实地独处。我的制片人亚历克斯认为这个故事的结尾太负面了，需要一点振奋人心、一些公共广播式的启发。亚历克斯建议说，我从这次经历中学到的是，我并不讨厌电视，而是讨厌看电视的自己，在我真正爱自己之前，我不会真正爱上电视。也许他是对的。我取消了有线电视。
David Rakoff. His latest book, Don't Get Too Comfortable.
大卫·拉科夫。他的最新著作《Don't Get Too Comfortable》。
[MUSIC- "LIKE U CRAZY" BY MATES OF STATE]
[音乐 - Mates of State的“LIKE U CRAZY”]
Mates of State.
Mates of State。
Act Two, Turkey's in Pilgrim Clothing. I think, actually, some really interesting moments of television come when a show attempts something that it never normally does, and especially, I think, when a comedy show decides it's going to get serious. Do you know what I mean? Like think about when Letterman talked to his own audience about September 11, or when he talked about his own heart attack, or, going back a ways, MASH killing off one of its own characters. When shows like that do that, it's moving and it's powerful. And it reminds you of what is great about those shows.
第二幕，《朝圣者装束的火鸡》。我认为，当一部电视剧尝试它平时从不做的尝试时，会产生一些非常有趣的电视时刻，特别是当一部喜剧片决定变得严肃时。你知道我的意思吗？想想当大卫·莱特曼（Letterman）向他的观众谈论9/11，或者谈论他自己的心脏病发作，或者往回追溯，像《陆军野战医院》（MASH）中杀掉其中一名主角时。当那些节目这样做时，既动人又有力，提醒你这些节目伟大在哪里。
But when a comedy show decides to get serious, it can also lead to Gary Coleman sitting on Nancy Reagan's knee and saying no to drugs. It's embarrassing. And it reminds you what is incredibly dumb about the shows. So what happens when comedies decide to take on the rather serious history of the United States of America? How do they do? Well, for insight into that, we turn to an expert, Sarah Vowell, who's in the middle of researching and writing a history of the pilgrims and puritans in America and who has reviewed the key TV episodes that handle this same material. Please welcome Sarah Vowell.
但当一部喜剧片决定变得严肃时，也可能导致加里·科尔曼（Gary Coleman）坐在南希·里根（Nancy Reagan）的膝盖上对毒品说“不”。那很尴尬，也提醒你这些节目有多么愚蠢。那么当喜剧决定触碰美利坚合众国相当严肃的历史时会发生什么呢？他们做得如何？为了深入了解，我们请来了一位专家，莎拉·沃威尔，她正在研究和撰写一部关于美国清教徒和朝圣者的历史，并回顾了处理相同素材的关键剧集。欢迎莎拉·沃威尔。
I was in third grade when I saw the Happy Days Thanksgiving episode, and I loved it. The whole cast was in pilgrim costumes. So that was great. And Joanie Cunningham complains that, "Being a pilgrim sure is a drageth." And the Fonz says things like, "Greetethamundo." Not to brag, but by third grade I was a veteran of four Thanksgiving pageants and considered myself to be something of a Mayflower expert.
我在三年级时看了《欢乐时光》（Happy Days）的感恩节特辑，我很喜欢。全体演员都穿上了朝圣者的服装，那太棒了。乔妮·坎宁安（Joanie Cunningham）抱怨说：“当朝圣者真是无聊透顶（a drageth）。”而方兹（Fonz）说出类似“Greeting-a-mundo”这样的台词。不是我自夸，三年级的时候，我已经是四个感恩节演出的老手了，自认为是个“五月花号”专家。
Or so I thought, up until the moment Joanie leaves the room and her goody-goody brother, Richie, asks, "Father, are you letting her go out like that? Have you seen her skirt? It's up to her ankles." I remember sitting there and watching that and realizing for the first of many times, oh, maybe the people who founded this country were kind of crazy.
或者是这么认为的，直到乔妮离开房间，她那循规蹈矩的哥哥里奇问：“爸爸，你真的让她那样出门吗？你看到她的裙子了吗？都到脚踝了。”我记得坐在那儿看着那一幕，第一次意识到——也许，这个国家的缔造者们有点疯。
There are actually a surprising number of sitcoms that have done episodes set in 17th century New England, even though 17th century New England is all situation and no comedy.
实际上，有相当多数量的情景喜剧制作了以17世纪新英格兰为背景的剧集，尽管17世纪的新英格兰全是“情境”而没有“喜剧”。
Here's how Mayflower passenger William Bradford described the pilgrims' first few months after arriving in Plymouth in 1620.
“五月花号”乘客威廉·布拉德福德（William Bradford）是这样描述朝圣者在1620年抵达普利茅斯后最初几个月的。
"Being ye depth of winter and wanting houses and other comforts, being infected with ye scurvie and other diseases which this long voyage had brought upon them, there died sometimes two or three a day."
“由于处于严冬，缺乏房屋和其他舒适条件，又感染了长途航行带来的坏血病和其他疾病，有时一天就有两三个人死去。”
Half of them died in the first year. Half. Starvation, lack of shelter, and-- this is appalling when you really think about it-- these were people with the farming skills of Mr. Magoo. And if that weren't enough, they were religious zealots. So they believed they deserved every misfortune visited upon them, because their beloved God apparently decided their lives should suck just a little bit more.
他们中有一半人在第一年就死了。一半。饥饿、缺乏住所——当你仔细想想，这真是令人震惊——这些人有着像Magoo先生一样的农业技能。如果这还不够，他们还是宗教狂热分子。所以他们相信自己受到的每一次不幸都是咎由自取，因为他们挚爱的上帝显然决定了他们的生活本该更糟一点。
Yet the Puritan episode is a sitcom staple, maybe because TV networks have to broadcast something on Thanksgiving. But even when a sitcom is trying to be about something bigger-- like history, or teen pregnancy, or underage drinking-- sitcoms are like people, they're self-absorbed. What they're most interested in is themselves. And when they do history, they always put their own characters at the center of the story.
然而，清教徒剧集是情景喜剧的必备要素，也许是因为电视网在感恩节必须播放点什么。但即使情景喜剧试图探讨更大的议题——比如历史、少女怀孕或未成年饮酒——情景喜剧就像人一样，它们是自我中心的。它们最感兴趣的是它们自己。当它们处理历史时，总是把自己的角色置于故事的中心。
Mr. Ed, the talking horse, tells the tale of the pilgrim horse who saved the first Thanksgiving. And if you were under the impression that the Salem witch trials ended because rich and powerful people started getting accused of witchcraft, think again. It was Samantha on Bewitched. Or take that Happy Days Thanksgiving episode in which it's revealed that the person who gave us Thanksgiving was not Squanto or William Bradford but the Fonz. That's right, the Fonz.
会说话的马“艾德先生”（Mr. Ed）讲述了拯救第一个感恩节的朝圣马的故事。如果你以为萨勒姆女巫审判是因为富人和权贵被指控为女巫而结束的，那你就想错了。那是《家有仙妻》（Bewitched）里的萨曼莎（Samantha）。或者看看那集《欢乐时光》的感恩节特辑，揭示出给我们带来感恩节的不是斯昆托（Squanto）或威廉·布拉德福德，而是方兹。没错，就是方兹。
Here's how it went down. All the pilgrims were afraid of the Indians except pilgrim Fonzie, who was their friend. Then Joanie gets her foot caught in one of Potsie's stupid beaver traps. That Potsie. But you know that thing Fonzie does with the jukebox? Where he whacks it with his fist and the music plays? Turns out that works on beaver traps too. They open right up. But he won't free Joanie until everyone renounces their racism, and acts nice to the Indians, and invites them to dinner. Fonzie, he's the Martin Luther King of candied yams.
事情是这样发展的：所有的朝圣者都害怕印第安人，除了朝圣者方兹，他是他们的朋友。然后乔妮的脚被波齐（Potsie）的一个愚蠢海狸陷阱夹住了。那个波齐。但你知道方兹对自动点唱机做的那个动作吗？用拳头敲一下音乐就响了？原来这对海狸陷阱也管用。它们立刻打开了。但他不肯放了乔妮，直到每个人都放弃种族主义，对印第安人好，并邀请他们共进晚餐。方兹，他就是蜜饯山药界的马丁·路德·金。
Mostly sitcom Puritans are rendered in the tone I like to call the boy, people used to be so stupid school of history. Bewitched produced not one but two time travel witch trial episodes, one for each Darrin. They're both diatribes about tolerance straight out of Arthur Miller's The Crucible , only crappier and with magical nose crinkles.
情景喜剧中的清教徒通常以我称之为“男孩，人们过去真够蠢”学派历史的基调呈现。《家有仙妻》不仅制作了一集，而是两集穿越时空的女巫审判剧，每个达林（Darrin）一集。它们都是直接照搬亚瑟·米勒（Arthur Miller）的《萨勒姆的女巫》（The Crucible）的宽容抨击，只是更烂，且加上了神奇的动鼻子特技。
Samantha brings a ballpoint pen with her to 17th century Salem, and the townspeople think it's an instrument of black magic. So they try her for witchcraft and want to hang her. I mean, can you believe those barbarian idiots with their cockamamie farce of a legal system, locking people up for fishy reasons and putting their criminals to death? Good thing Americans put an end to all that nonsense long ago.
萨曼莎带了一支圆珠笔到17世纪的萨勒姆，镇民们以为那是黑魔法工具，所以审判她巫术并想绞死她。我是说，你能相信那些野蛮的白痴，用他们那荒唐的法律系统把人关起来，并处决罪犯吗？好在美国人很久以前就终结了所有那些胡言乱语。
The biggest thing sitcoms gloss over about Plymouth is the most important fact of life there, the suffering. But in 1999, there was one sitcom that tried something daring. It included all the normal sitcom characters-- the wacky neighbor, the hard to please mother-in-law, the bumbling dad-- but it also reveled in and dwelled on the grim brutality of life in colonial New England. It was set entirely in 1621 Plymouth. It was called, Thanks -- as in Thanksgiving, as in thanks a lot.
情景喜剧对普利茅斯粉饰太平的最大一点，是那里最重要的生活事实：苦难。但在1999年，有一部情景喜剧尝试了一些大胆的东西。它包括了所有典型的情景喜剧角色——古怪的邻居、难以取悦的岳母、笨手笨脚的父亲——但它也陶醉于并沉溺于殖民地新英格兰生活的冷酷残暴。它完全设定在1621年的普利茅斯。它叫《感谢》（Thanks）——就像感恩节的那个感谢，也像“多谢你了”那种反讽。
I know you never saw it, which is probably why it was canceled after six weeks. But I loved it. Thanks involved two of my favorite, but usually separate, things-- TV and American history-- coming together. Imagine if you were an avid stamp collector, and you found out that CBS was about to debut its new series, CSI: Philately . You'd be psyched.
我知道你们从没看过，这大概就是它六周后就被砍的原因。但我爱它。《感谢》结合了我最喜欢的两样东西——电视和美国历史——但它们通常是分开的。想象一下，如果你是一个热衷集邮的人，发现CBS准备首播新剧《CSI：集邮调查》，你会疯掉的。
Even the most idealistic and cheerful character on Thanks -- the dad, James Winthrop-- welcomes in the spring saying, "What a beautiful day it is. The snow is melting, everyone out and about airing out their clothes, lugging out their dead." James Winthrop is surely modeled on John Winthrop, the first governor of Massachusetts and author of the famous hopeful sermon about how he and his fellow Englishmen are to be as a city upon a hill.
即使是《感谢》中最理想主义、最乐观的角色——父亲詹姆斯·温思罗普（James Winthrop）——也在欢迎春天时说：“多么美好的一天啊。雪正在融化，大家出来通风晾晒衣服，搬运死尸。”詹姆斯·温思罗普无疑是以马萨诸塞州第一任州长约翰·温思罗普为原型，他写过那篇著名的、充满希望的布道词，讲述他和他的英国同胞要成为“山巅之城”。
On Thanks that sort of idealism is literally a joke. Says Winthrop, "We're not the kind of people who are easily discouraged by a few snow flurries, a couple of head colds, the 50% mortality rate. No, we're pilgrims, strong-willed people who never give up. He's wrong. The only thing his fellow residents of New England want is to get the hell back to old England.
在《感谢》中，那种理想主义简直就是个笑话。温思罗普说：“我们不是那种会被一点点雪花、几次感冒、50%死亡率轻易吓倒的人。不，我们是朝圣者，意志坚强的永不放弃的人。”他错了。他那些新英格兰居民唯一的愿望就是赶紧滚回古老的英格兰。
The genius of Thanks was that it was a kind of meta-sitcom, making jokes out of standard sitcom ingredients. The funniest ongoing gag involved Abigail-- your typical, sitcom, teenage, bombshell daughter. After a disagreement with her parents about boys, she lets loose the sort of routine, girl outburst that's been seen on prime time since the dawn of Gidget.
《感谢》的天才之处在于它是一种后现代情景喜剧，把典型的情景喜剧元素变成了笑料。最有趣的持续梗涉及阿比盖尔（Abigail）——你典型的、情景喜剧式的、美貌少女女儿。在与父母因男孩问题产生分歧后，她发泄出那种自从《吉奇》（Gidget）开播以来在黄金时段就司空见惯的女孩式爆发。
"I hate my life," she yells. But where a modern TV teenager would run upstairs and slam the door to her room, the 17th century teenager lives in a tiny, one-room cabin. So she can only run about a foot and a half before she throws herself face first onto a bed, right next to the table where everyone would eat if there was any food.
“我恨我的生活，”她喊道。但如果是一个现代电视里的青少年，会跑上楼把房间门关上，可17世纪的青少年住在一个狭窄、单间的木屋里。所以她只能跑大约一英尺半，然后脸朝下扑到床上，正好就在如果有什么食物时大家会吃饭的桌子旁边。
Thanks was so refreshing because of its frankness, especially compared to earlier sitcoms. In one scene, Mrs. Winthrop meets Squanto, the famous English-speaking Indian. She asks him, "What are you doing in our neck of the woods?"
《感谢》之所以让人耳目一新，是因为它的坦率，特别是与早期的情景喜剧相比。在一个场景中，温思罗普夫人遇到了斯昆托，那个著名的会说英语的印第安人。她问他：“你在我们这一带干什么？”
Squanto answers, "Actually, we like to think of it as our neck of the woods." That's pretty much the whole story right there. It's so quick and clean and concise. Plymouth was actually built on the site of Squanto's hometown, Patuxet. All his friends and family, his whole village, died from the diseases that arrived with earlier European visitors. Squanto is hanging around because it's the only home he knows. That's why he's there to help the incompetent white people grow corn, using the seeds they'd stolen from some other Indians on Cape Cod.
斯昆托回答：“其实，我们更倾向于认为这是我们这一带。”这基本上就是整个故事的要点。它非常简洁、清晰、有力。普利茅斯实际上是建在斯昆托的家乡帕图克塞特（Patuxet）遗址上的。他所有的朋友和家人，他的整个村庄，都死于随早期欧洲访客而来的疾病。斯昆托在那里游荡，因为那是他唯一知道的家。这就是为什么他在那里帮助无能的白人种植玉米，使用他们从科德角其他印第安人那里偷来的种子。
'We like to think of it as our neck of the woods." There's so much meaning in that one little wise crack. It shows you history doesn't have to be trampled by the sitcom format.
“我们倾向于认为这是我们这一带。”那一句简短的讽刺中有着太多的含义。它向你展示了历史不需要被情景喜剧格式所践踏。
Here's another example. There's a crackerjack Thanksgiving dinner scene in the pilgrim episode of The Simpsons . Ned Flanders-- playing the purest of all the Puritans-- is talking to Indian Chief Wiggum. Get it? And Flanders says, "Chief Wiggum, we could never have survived our first year in the New World without you. I almost regret what we Europeans are going to do to you."
这里有另一个例子。《辛普森一家》（The Simpsons）中那一集朝圣者剧集里，有一场很棒的感恩节晚餐场景。内德·弗兰德斯（Ned Flanders）——饰演最纯洁的清教徒——正与印第安威格姆酋长对话。懂了吗？弗兰德斯说：“威格姆酋长，如果没有你，我们在新世界的头一年绝不可能活下来。我几乎后悔我们要对你们做的事情了。”
Chief Wiggum, "What are you going to do?"
威格姆酋长：“你们要干什么？”
Flanders, "Oh, give you the biggest slice of pumpkin pie. Also, we're going to take your land and wipe you out. Who wants whipped topping?"
弗兰德斯：“哦，分给你们最大块的南瓜派。另外，我们要夺走你们的土地并消灭你们。谁想加点奶油？”
Flanders isn't embarrassed about the harsh story of America. If anything, he's cheerful. And there's something sort of profound about that combination. In fact, the greatest sitcom characters-- which is to say, the funniest and the most riveting to watch-- are cheerful at the same time that they're self-absorbed, and galling, and oblivious to the destruction left in their wake. Think Homer Simpson, Michael Scott on The Office , Ted Baxter from Mary Tyler Moore , Larry David, the entire cast of Seinfeld .
弗兰德斯对美国残酷的历史并不感到尴尬。如果有什么的话，他甚至很愉快。这种组合有一种深刻的含义。事实上，最伟大的情景喜剧角色——也就是最有趣、最引人入胜的角色——都是在自我中心、招人厌、对身后留下的破坏毫无察觉的同时，保持着愉快的态度。想想荷马·辛普森、《办公室》里的迈克尔·斯科特（Michael Scott）、《玛丽·泰勒·摩尔秀》里的泰德·巴克斯特（Ted Baxter）、拉里·大卫（Larry David）、《宋飞正传》（Seinfeld）的全班人马。
And you know what else is like that? The United States of America. I don't know why you would applaud that.
你知道还有什么是这样的吗？美利坚合众国。我不知道你们为什么要为这个鼓掌。
That's why it doesn't really matter if these pilgrim episodes are factually accurate, because sitcoms tell the true story of our nation every time the Michaels, and Homers, and Larrys open their mouths. We're well-meaning, lovable, unintentionally destructive, believing we're more important than we are, like we're some kind of city upon a hill. Thank you.
这就是为什么这些清教徒剧集在事实上是否准确并不重要，因为每当迈克尔们、荷马们和拉里们张嘴时，情景喜剧都在讲述我们国家真实的篇章。我们是好意的、可爱的、无意中造成破坏的，相信自己比实际更重要，就像我们是什么“山巅之城”一样。谢谢。
Sarah Vowell is the author of Assassination Vacation and other books with surprisingly funny histories of America in them. Her upcoming book about the Puritans is called, The Wordy Shipmates. Coming up, which is more powerful, television or family? That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
莎拉·沃威尔是《暗杀度假》（Assassination Vacation）及其他著作的作者，书里都有令人吃惊的有趣美国历史。她即将出版的关于清教徒的书叫《The Wordy Shipmates》。接下来，电视和家庭哪个更强大？稍后回来，来自芝加哥公共广播和公共广播国际公司。
[MUSIC- "GOODS (INSTRUMENTAL)" BY MATES OF STATE]
[音乐 - Mates of State的“GOODS (INSTRUMENTAL)”]
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program we choose a theme and bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, What I Learned From Television. And by that, I mean what we all learned from television. We've arrived at Act Three. Act Three, Radio on the TV.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们都会选择一个主题，并带来各种关于该主题的故事。今天的节目，“我们从电视中学到了什么”。我指的是我们大家从电视中学到的东西。我们到了第三幕。第三幕，《电视上的广播》。
OK, so we just finished shooting and editing this weekly television show. And the main thing I want to say to you is, the radio show is not going off the air. So the strangest experience I had during this period-- the strangest thing I actually learned from TV-- came while we were putting together our television show. But it didn't actually come from anything that we worked on.
好的，我们刚刚制作并剪辑完成了这个周播电视节目。我想对你们说的最重要的一点是：广播节目不会停播。我在这一期间经历的最奇怪的事——我从电视上学到的最奇怪的事——发生在我们要整理电视节目的时候。但这其实并不是来自我们工作的任何内容。
One Thursday night, I was watching The O.C. with my wife, Anaheed. I don't know if you're watching The O.C. , or were watching it before it got taken off. I loved that show. It's kind of a great, funny, interesting show. If you have no idea what I'm talking about, go to season one, rent the Chrismukkah episode, OK? And it was a teen soap opera on the FOX network. And the main couple was Seth and Summer, not Marissa and Ryan. They could have killed off Marissa back in season one, as far as I was concerned.
一个周四晚上，我和妻子阿娜希德（Anaheed）在看《橘郡风云》（The O.C.）。我不知道你是否在看，或者在它停播前是否看过。我喜欢那个节目。它是那种很棒、很有趣、很有吸引力的节目。如果你不知道我在说什么，去租第一季的“光明节”（Chrismukkah）那一集，好吗？那是福克斯电视网的一部青少年肥皂剧。主角是一对：塞斯（Seth）和萨默（Summer），而不是玛丽莎和瑞安。依我看，他们早该在第一季就把玛丽莎写死了。
And so there's the scene-- this particular Thursday night-- where Seth is in his room talking to his girlfriend, Summer, on the phone. And a girl is in his room. It's Taylor, who is basically the same character as Paris on The Gilmore Girls , but that's a whole other thing. And so there's this girl in his room. And Summer hears this girl's voice in her boyfriend's room. And she asks him about it. And this moment happens.
就在这个周四晚上，有一场戏：塞斯在房间里，正用电话跟女友萨默说话。而有一个女孩在他房间里。那是泰勒（Taylor），基本上和《吉尔莫女孩》里的帕里斯（Paris）是一个角色，但那是另外一回事了。总之那个女孩在他房间里。萨默在电话里听到了塞斯房间里有女孩的声音。她问了他。然后这一刻发生了。
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
[音频回放]
-That sounded like a girl.
——那听起来像个女孩。
-Did it? Yeah. Well, sure. Because I'm listening to the radio. And This American Life is on. And so there's a girl talking.
——是吗？是的。嗯，当然。因为我在听广播。正在播《美国生活》。所以有个女孩在说话。
[END AUDIO PLAYBACK]
[结束音频回放]
OK, and then Summer makes this reply, which, I have to say, just totally--
好的，然后萨默给出了这个回应，我必须说，简直太——
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
[音频回放]
-Is that that show by those hipster know-it-alls who talk about how fascinating ordinary people are? Ekhh. God.
——是那群嬉皮士聪明鬼谈论普通人有多迷人的那个节目吗？额。天哪。
[END PLAYBACK]
[结束回放]
Is that that show by those hipster know-it-alls who talk about how fascinating ordinary people are? Ekhh. I have to say, I had this experience where I was just like-- it was like having fictional characters on the FOX network, like, they said my name. And I literally stood up and went like-- like did that just happen? And it just totally was like, was this on everybody's TiVo? Or is this just like--
是那群嬉皮士聪明鬼谈论普通人有多迷人的那个节目吗？额。我必须说，我有过那种体验，就好像福克斯电视网上的虚构角色叫了我的名字。我真的站了起来，心想——刚发生了什么？这难道在每个人的TiVo里都有吗？还是说——
And you know, radio is so different from television. And as we've been making our television show, people keep asking me which is better?
你知道，广播和电视是非常不同的。在我们制作电视节目时，人们总是问我哪个更好？
You know what I mean? People ask me this all the time now. So which is it going to be? Is it going to be radio or TV? Which is better? Like we're all going to have to choose sides between radio and TV because there's going to be a big war. You know.
你知道我的意思吗？现在人们总是问我这个问题。所以到底选哪个？是广播还是电视？哪个更好？好像我们都要在广播和电视之间站队，因为要有一场大战发生。你知道的。
And in fact, actually, there was a war. And radio kind of lost that war.
事实上，确实发生过一场战争。而广播在那种战争中算是输了。
And the fact is, radio and TV-- they're just good for different things. Radio is so intimate and personal. And TV can be so weirdly grand in what it does. And just thinking about The O. C. and the other shows I love-- I have to say-- thinking about this moment, I realize that my feelings about my favorite shows on television, they are exactly the same as my feelings about the shows that I love on the radio. The things I love, I love completely. And it's totally personal, my feelings about these shows. It's personal in the deepest possible way.
事实是，广播和电视——它们只是擅长不同的事。广播是如此私密和个人化。而电视在它所做的事情上可以变得如此奇异地宏大。想想《橘郡风云》和我爱的其他节目——我不得不说——想到那一刻，我意识到我对最爱电视节目的感受，和我对广播中喜爱的节目的感受完全一样。我所爱的东西，我全心全意地去爱。我对这些节目的感受是完全私人的。它以最深刻的方式与我个人相关。
And I'm a kind of dorky fan when it comes to stuff. My wife is here in the room. So maybe this is bad to be telling this story. Every week, The O. C. comes on, and my wife, Anaheed, and I, we sit on the couch. And when the theme comes on, "California," we sing along with it in full voice. Do you know what I mean?
说到这些，我还是个书呆子粉丝。我的妻子就在房间里，所以讲这个故事可能不太好。每周《橘郡风云》播出时，我和妻子阿娜希德坐在沙发上。当主题曲“California”响起时，我们大声跟着唱。你知道我的意思吗？
Think about what that takes. I'm 47 years old. I'm a grown ass man, you know? We're a married couple. Sober. We are sober, singing the theme to a FOX show.
想想看这需要多大的勇气。我47岁了。我是个成熟的男人，你知道吗？我们是已婚夫妻。清醒的。我们是清醒的，跟着唱福克斯节目的主题曲。
And I have got to say, every single week it makes me love my wife, and love TV, and love everything in the world all at once. And last week, when The O.C. went off TV, I cried. And I'm not ashamed to admit it.
我必须说，每周它都让我爱我的妻子，爱电视，爱世上的一切。上周，《橘郡风云》停播时，我哭了。我不以承认这点为耻。
[MUSIC - "CALIFORNIA" MATES OF STATE]
[音乐 - Mates of State的“CALIFORNIA”]
Mates of State. A married couple singing that song.
Mates of State。一对唱着那首歌的已婚夫妻。
Act Four, My Other Dog's a German Shepherd. Well, Dan Savage has this story of what a person can and can not learn from television, a story drawing from his own experience. A quick warning to listeners. There's nothing explicit in Dan's story at all. But he does use a slang word to refer to gay people. A word that is actually perfectly OK for him to use, but not necessarily something you will want your six-year-old child to repeat. So take that under advisement. Here's Dan Savage.
第四幕，《我的另一条狗是德国牧羊犬》。好吧，丹·萨维奇（Dan Savage）有一个关于一个人能从电视上学到什么和学不到什么的故事，这个故事源于他自己的经验。给听众一个简单的警告。丹的故事里没有任何露骨的东西。但他确实用了一个俚语来称呼同性恋者。这是一个对他来说完全可以使用的词，但不一定是你希望六岁孩子重复的。请慎重收听。这是丹·萨维奇。
My dad liked to watch cop shows. He was a cop, a homicide detective assigned to Chicago's seedy, gay neighborhood in the '70s. And like all cops, what he most enjoyed about watching cop shows was pointing out where they got it wrong. There was just one show on TV that got police work even slightly right-- according to my dad-- Barney Miller, which ran on ABC from 1975-- when I was eleven-- to 1982-- when I was 17. The officers on Barney Miller weren't beat cops. They were detectives, like my dad. Their jobs were tedious, like my dad's-- all paperwork and bad coffee, no car chases, no shootouts. And the detectives were middle aged and out of shape, like my dad. And like my dad, the detectives on Barney Miller policed a seedy, gay neighborhood, New York City's Greenwich Village.
我爸爸喜欢看警匪片。他是一名警察，70年代被指派到芝加哥阴暗的同性恋社区负责谋杀案的警探。像所有警察一样，他在看警匪片时最喜欢的事就是指出他们哪里搞错了。只有一部电视节目能稍微准确地还原警察工作——根据我爸爸的说法——那就是从1975年（我11岁时）到1982年（我17岁时）在ABC播出的《巴尼·米勒》（Barney Miller）。《巴尼·米勒》里的警官不是巡警。他们是警探，像我爸爸一样。他们的工作很乏味，像我爸爸一样——全是文书工作和难喝的咖啡，没有飞车追逐，没有枪战。而且这些警探人到中年，体态走形，像我爸爸一样。而且像我爸爸一样，《巴尼·米勒》里的警探负责的是一个阴暗的同性恋社区，纽约市的格林威治村。
There was a recurring gay character on Barney Miller , one of the first on television. Very swishy, total stereotype, carried a purse, owned a poodle. My dad liked cop movies too. And I remember watching one in particular with my dad-- The Choir boys, a 1977 movie-- in our living room some time after it came out on video. And how's this for a coincidence? The cops in Choir boys policed Los Angeles' seedy, gay neighborhood. And in one scene, a guy-- one of the cops-- is handcuffed to a tree in a cruisy park and left there with his pants around his ankles.
《巴尼·米勒》里有一个反复出现的同性恋角色，是电视上最早出现的角色之一。非常“娘娘腔”，标准的刻板印象，带着手提包，养着贵宾犬。我爸爸也喜欢看警察电影。我记得有一次在录影带发行后，在客厅和爸爸看了一部特定的电影——1977年的《唱诗班男孩》（The Choirboys）。巧合的是，那部电影里的警察负责的正是洛杉矶阴暗的同性恋社区。其中一幕，一个警察被铐在公园的树上，裤子拉到脚踝处。
And who should come upon this helpless, bare-assed cop first? A swish carrying a purse, walking a poodle. He takes one look at the cop and says, "I can't believe it. A naked man chained to a tree. That's a crazy, mad, salacious dream." They speak briefly-- the swish and the naked cop.
谁会先碰到这个无助、光着屁股的警察呢？一个拿着手提包、遛着贵宾犬的“娘娘腔”。他看了一眼那个警察，说：“真不敢相信。一个光着身子的男人被锁在树上。这真是个疯狂、变态、淫荡的梦。”他们简短地交流了一下——那个“娘娘腔”和光屁股警察。
The cop threatens him, "I'll kill you if you touch me, you fag son of a bitch." This is played for laughs. "I'll rip your damn kidneys. I'll punch your spleen."
那个警察威胁他：“再碰我我就宰了你，你这个同性恋杂种。”这被当作笑料呈现。“我要挖出你的肾。我要揍烂你的脾。”
The swish replies, "You'd do that for me?" The swish leaves with his poodle, which is dyed pink.
那个“娘娘腔”回答：“你会那样对我吗？”那个“娘娘腔”带着他的贵宾犬离开了，狗被染成了粉红色。
Watching that with my dad when I was a teenager made me want to die because I knew I would be some kind of fag when I grew up and so did he. I wasn't ready to talk about it with him. And he certainly wasn't going to go anywhere near the subject. So when gays popped up on TV-- something that, inconveniently enough, began to happen with greater and greater frequency just as I hit puberty-- things got awkward.
十几岁时和我爸爸看那部电影让我恨不得去死，因为我知道我长大后会是某种同性恋，他也知道。我不准备和他谈论这个。他当然也不会去触碰这个话题。所以当电视上出现同性恋——很不巧，这恰好在我进入青春期时发生得越来越频繁——事情就变得尴尬了。
I'm sure we both sat there during The Choirboys in silence. Here was this subject we were avoiding at all costs. And all of the sudden, we were ambushed by the television set. I found out years later that he was fine with me being gay, and that the reason he didn't laugh or react to scenes with gay characters on TV was that he didn't want to make me feel bad. At the time, I interpreted his silence as a quietly simmering anger and disgust.
我敢肯定，在《唱诗班男孩》播出时，我们俩都沉默地坐在那里。这里有我们尽一切代价回避的话题。突然间，我们被电视机伏击了。多年后我才知道他并不介意我是同性恋，而他没有对电视上的同性恋角色场景大笑或做出反应，是因为他不想让我感到难受。当时，我把他的沉默解读为一种悄悄积压的愤怒和厌恶。
And sitting in front of the TV, I made a resolution. I was going to be some kind of fag when I grow up, but I wasn't going to be that kind of fag. I wouldn't carry a purse. And I would never come upon a half-naked cop, chained to a tree in a cruisy park, late at night, because I wasn't going to be walking any poodles around cruisy parks late at night, because I wasn't going to own a poodle. That's what I learned from television. Don't own a poodle.
坐在电视机前，我下了一个决心。我长大后会成为某种同性恋，但我不会成为那种同性恋。我不会带手提包。我也永远不会在深夜某个公园遇到一个被锁在树上的半裸警察，因为我不会在深夜公园里遛贵宾犬，因为我绝不会养贵宾犬。这就是我从电视上学到的。别养贵宾犬。
I made up my mind to be a different sort of homo, not like the gay people you saw on TV, which were the only gay people I ever saw.
我下定决心要成为另一种同性恋，不像电视上看到的那些，因为那是我见过的唯一的同性恋。
And straight people, I figured-- my dad, Jerry Falwell, Anita Bryant-- they were going to like me. That's when I stopped giving a damn about how gays were portrayed on TV. And for years, whenever a friend would complain about gays on television, I would grant them that, yes, most of the gay people on television were stereotypes. But was the portrayal of heterosexuals on television any better? Do real straight people act anything like those crazy ass breeders on Desperate Housewives? Do real straight people act like the fake straight people on Lost ? Does anyone act like the people on Lost? Do real straight people act like Tom Cruise on Oprah ?
至于异性恋，我想——我爸爸、杰瑞·福尔韦尔（Jerry Falwell）、安妮塔·布莱恩特（Anita Bryant）——他们会喜欢我。那时我就不再关心电视上是如何描绘同性恋的了。多年来，每当有朋友抱怨电视上的同性恋，我都会承认，是的，电视上大多数同性恋都是刻板印象。但电视上对异性恋的描绘就好吗？现实中的异性恋表现得像《绝望主妇》里那些疯狂的繁殖者吗？现实中的异性恋表现得像《迷失》里的假异性恋吗？有人会表现得像《迷失》里的那些人吗？现实中的异性恋表现得像奥普拉节目里的汤姆·克鲁斯吗？
Only an idiot-- I would tell my friends-- would look to television to form a picture of what straight people are really like. An idiot. Or a child. Perhaps a child with gay parents. As soon as our adopted son D.J.-- who's eight now-- was old enough to use the TV remote, I felt like I was regressing to my early teenage years, suddenly worried again about how sexuality is portrayed on television. But not my sexuality. His. Heterosexuality.
只有白痴——我会告诉我的朋友——才会指望通过电视去构想现实中的异性恋是什么样的。白痴。或者是孩子。也许是一个有同性恋家长的孩子。当我们的养子D.J.（现在8岁）大到可以使用电视遥控器时，我觉得自己仿佛退回了青春期早期，再次担心电视上是如何描绘性取向的。但不是我的性取向，是他的。异性恋。
Now before we go any further, a word about why I say with such confidence that my son is straight. The first time he picked up a football he tossed a perfect spiral. He's into trucks not dolls. If it can't be used as a gun, it's not a toy he's interested in owning. I know D.J.'s straight the same way my parents knew I was gay. And I know D.J. is now learning about his sexuality watching television, just as I once learned about mine watching television. And the treatment of heterosexuality, on just one show in particular, offends me so terribly that I've tried to stop him from watching it. And I'm not talking about Nip/Tuck , or The Sopranos , or I Love New York . We wouldn't let him watch those shows if he wanted to. And he doesn't want to. Those shows, to him, are just grown-ups shouting at each other. And he doesn't have to watch TV for that.
现在，在我们继续之前，先解释一下为什么我如此自信地说我的儿子是异性恋。他第一次拿起橄榄球时就投出了完美的螺旋球。他喜欢卡车而不是洋娃娃。如果不能当枪用，他就对那玩具没兴趣。我知道D.J.是异性恋，就像我父母知道我是同性恋一样。我知道D.J.现在正像我当年一样，通过电视学习有关他性取向的知识。而电视中对异性恋的处理，特别是在某一个节目中，冒犯了我，以至于我试图阻止他观看。我指的不是《整容室》（Nip/Tuck）、《黑道家族》（The Sopranos）或《我爱纽约》（I Love New York）。如果他想看那些节目，我们也不会让他看。而他也不想看。对他来说，那些节目只是成年人在互吼。他不需要看电视看这个。
No, this is a show for kids on the Disney channel, one of the most popular shows on TV. It's already two video games. And it's a show D.J. adores. The Suite Life of Zack and Cody is about twin brothers who live in a hotel in Boston, the Tipton, where their divorced mom works as a cabaret singer. So it's Suite Life -- S-U-I-T-E, not S-W-E-E-T.
不，这是一部迪斯尼频道的儿童节目，电视上最受欢迎的节目之一。它已经衍生出两款电子游戏，而且D.J.非常喜欢。这部《小查与寇弟的顶级生活》（The Suite Life of Zack and Cody）讲述了住在波士顿一家酒店——提普顿（Tipton）酒店——的一对双胞胎兄弟，他们的离异母亲在那里当酒吧歌手。所以那是《顶级生活》（Suite Life）——S-U-I-T-E，而不是S-W-E-E-T。
The boys are always getting into crazy scrapes and hatching hair-brained schemes. They're preteens-- 10 or 11. Now in some ways, this show defies stereotypes. There's a character named London-- spoiled rich girl played by an Asian actress-- but get this, she's Asian but she's dumb. And then there's Maddie, a teenaged girl who works at the hotel candy shop, played by a blond actress, but she's smart. And then there's Mr. Moseby, the hotel manager, played by a black actor. But he's fussy. Some might go so far as to say clean and articulate.
男孩们总是陷入疯狂的纠纷并孵化疯狂的计划。他们是学龄前儿童——10或11岁。在某些方面，这个节目挑战了刻板印象。有个角色叫伦敦（London）——被宠坏的富家女，由亚裔女演员扮演——但听好了，她是亚裔，但很笨。然后是麦迪（Maddie），在酒店糖果店工作的少女，由金发女演员扮演，但她很聪明。然后是莫斯比先生（Mr. Moseby），酒店经理，由黑人演员扮演，但他很挑剔。有些人甚至会说他干净利落、口齿伶俐。
But what offends me-- what worries me-- is how horny one of the twins always seems to be. Zack is sexually precocious in a deeply creepy way. Can a pre-pubescent boy be sexually precocious in a way that isn't deeply creepy?
但让我感到被冒犯——令我担忧的——是其中一个双胞胎总是看起来那么好色。查克（Zack）以一种极其令人毛骨悚然的方式在性方面表现得早熟。学龄前男孩能在不让人感到毛骨悚然的情况下性早熟吗？
Zack is also the more charismatic twin. Zack is Lucy to Cody's Ethel-- more athletic, more of a risk-taker. And Zack wants, aches for, pines for, goes for Maddie, the smart blond that works in the candy counter in the lobby. Maddie is 16 or 17, which is to say, Zack is in elementary school, Maddie is in high school.
查克也是更有魅力的双胞胎。查克是科迪（Cody）的露西——更具运动天赋，更爱冒险。查克想要、渴望、怀念、追求麦迪——那个在大厅糖果柜台工作的聪明金发女孩。麦迪16或17岁，也就是说，查克在上小学，而麦迪在上高中。
I don't let D.J. watch TV alone much. So I'll plop down on the couch with a book and sit with him, which is how I caught episodes of Suite Life where Zack worries about Maddie hooking up with other guys, and episodes where Zack instructs other little boys on the art of talking to babes. His advice, you lie to babes. In one particular episode, "A Prom Story," Zack walks up to Maddie and-- well let's just read the dialogue.
我不太让D.J.独自看电视。所以我会带本书坐在沙发上陪他，这就是我捕捉到几集《顶级生活》的原因，查克担心麦迪和其他男人勾搭，还有查克教其他小男孩撩妹艺术的集数。他的建议是：对妹子撒谎。在其中一集“舞会故事”中，查克走向麦迪——好吧，让我们读一下台词。
Zack-- looking Maddie up and down-- "Hey, sweet thing. What's the special today? I hope it's tall, blond and curvy."
查克——上下打量着麦迪——“嘿，甜心。今天有什么特别的吗？我希望是又高、又金、又曲线玲珑的。”
I'm not sure how a teenager would react to being hit on by a 10-year-old boy in real life because it never happens. But somehow, fictional Zack escapes the humiliation or the punch in the chest that a real life Zack would be subjected to. Instead, Zack emerges from this encounter with the impression that Maddie has just asked him to go with her to her prom. Zack runs up to Cody.
我不确定现实生活中的青少年在被一个10岁男孩调戏时会有什么反应，因为那种事从没发生过。但不知何故，虚构的查克逃过了现实中查克会遭遇的羞辱或胸口挨的一拳。相反，查克从这次遭遇中得出的印象是，麦迪刚刚邀请他参加她的舞会。查克跑向科迪。
Zack, excited-- "Did you hear that? Maddie wants to dance with me at her prom. I'd better practice my kissing." Cody, nauseated-- "Don't look at me."
查克，兴奋地——“你听到了吗？麦迪想在舞会上跟我跳舞。我最好练习一下接吻。”科迪，作呕地——“别看我。”
That is a threefer right there. You've got your horny, pre-pubescent boy, and an incest joke, and a cliche homophobic reaction to the idea of two boys kissing, brothers or not. Good stuff. Thanks, Disney.
那真是“三连击”。你有了好色的、学龄前的男孩，一个乱伦笑话，还有一个对两个男孩（无论是否亲兄弟）接吻这一想法的陈词滥调的恐同反应。好东西。谢谢，迪斯尼。
And here's why this show worries me so much. D.J. watches Suite Life of Zack and Cody with a look of concentration on his face, a look he doesn't get watching any other shows, a look we certainly don't get when we're talking to him. He looks like he's filing things away for future reference. For a boy without older brothers, a boy without straight male uncles or cousins living nearby, we worry that the way Zack treats women could be a problem every bit as damaging to a young straight boy as those images of gay men with poodles were to me.
这就是为什么这个节目让我如此担心的原因。D.J.看《小查与寇弟的顶级生活》时神情专注，这是他在看其他节目时没有的表情，当我们跟他说话时他绝对不会有这种表情。他看起来像是在归档以供将来参考。对于一个没有年长哥哥、没有住得近的异性恋男性叔叔或堂兄弟的男孩来说，我们担心查克对待女性的方式可能会成为一个极其有害的问题，就像当年那些养贵宾犬的同性恋形象对我造成的伤害一样。
I cling to one hope. Despite my exposure to all those swishy gay men walking poodles on TV during my formative years, I grew up to be a different kind of gay. And despite the girl-crazy little boys D.J. Sees on the Disney channel, he may grow up to be a different kind of straight. Maybe we'll both defy the stereotypes. The only problem with that is fate. You can defy a stereotype. You can work against it. But sometimes stereotypes are patient. They'll wait you out, wear you down, lull you into a false sense of security. And then bam, you own a poodle.
我坚持一个希望。尽管我在成长期接触到了所有电视上那些遛着贵宾犬的同性恋男人，我最终长大成为了一种不同类型的同性恋。尽管D.J.在迪斯尼频道看到的那些迷恋女孩的小男孩，他也许会长大成为一种不同类型的异性恋。也许我们都会打破刻板印象。唯一的麻烦是命运。你可以打破刻板印象，你可以努力对抗它。但有时刻板印象很有耐心。它们会等待你，消磨你，让你陷入虚假的安全感。然后砰的一声，你就有了一只贵宾犬。
D.J. asked for a poodle a few years ago. And I know how awful that sounds. The son of two gay men begins to adopt the homosexual lifestyle, poodles and all. Purses are next. And he didn't want any poodle, he wanted a toy poodle. A poodle he planned to name Pierre.
D.J.几年前要了一只贵宾犬。我知道听起来有多糟。两个同性恋男人的儿子开始采用同性恋生活方式，包括贵宾犬。接下来就是手提包了。他不是想要任何贵宾犬，他想要一只玩具贵宾犬。他打算给那只狗起名叫皮埃尔（Pierre）。
I tried to stop it-- selfishly, for my own sake-- but framing every argument in concern for D.J. We can't do this to him, I told my boyfriend. He's already got gay parents and I'm one of them. Isn't that a big enough pink cross to bear? Did we really intend to nail a poodle to it too?
我试图阻止它——出于自私，为了我自己——但把每一个争论都包装成对D.J.的关切。我告诉我的伴侣，我们不能对他这样做。他已经有两个同性恋家长了，我是其中之一。这难道不是一个足够大的粉红色十字架要承受了吗？我们真的打算把一只贵宾犬也钉在上面吗？
But D.J. was adamant. He had a friend, a little boy with opposite sex parents-- that's what we call those mixed gender couples. And his friend with the opposite sex parents had a toy poodle. These people recruited my son. These opposite sex poodle parent people. That's what poodle people do. They lure people into their poodle lifestyle.
但D.J.很坚持。他有个朋友，一对异性父母——这就是我们对那些不同性别的伴侣的称呼。他的那个有异性父母的朋友有一只玩具贵宾犬。这些人招募了我的儿子。那些异性恋贵宾犬家长。这就是贵宾犬主人们做的事。他们诱导人们进入他们的贵宾犬生活方式。
We did manage to talk D.J. into a less gay name for his toy poodle. Stinker has just one eye, is completely deaf, doesn't come when you call him, and runs into walls and chairs and trees. And D.J. loves him.
我们确实设法说服D.J.给他的玩具贵宾犬起了一个没那么“同性恋”的名字。Stinker只有一只眼睛，完全失聪，叫它也不过来，还撞墙、撞椅子、撞树。但D.J.很爱它。
I know all about Stinker's habit of running into trees because I'm the one that gets stuck walking the dog. We live on Capitol Hill in Seattle, which is Seattle's gay neighborhood. And there's a big park near our house, Seattle's crusiest, Volunteer Park. You can find the volunteers under every bush. And you can often find me there, late at night, walking the poodle.
我知道Stinker撞树的习惯，因为是我得负责溜狗。我们住在西雅图的国会山（Capitol Hill），那是西雅图的同性恋社区。我们房子附近有一个大公园，西雅图最适合勾搭人的Volunteer公园。你可以在每一丛灌木下找到志愿者（Volunteer）。而深夜，你经常能在那儿发现我，溜着那只贵宾犬。
I want to scream whenever someone passes me, "It's not my poodle. It's my straight son's poodle. I swear." Somehow, my straight son managed to get me out on the streets with a poodle. So I have to believe that we-- as a family-- exert a more powerful influence than television ultimately, and that we can help D.J. gracefully adjust to girl-crazy, when his time comes, the same way he helped me adjust to Stinker.
每当有人经过我身边，我都想大叫：“这不是我的贵宾犬。这是我异性恋儿子的贵宾犬。我发誓。”不知何故，我的异性恋儿子成功地把我弄到了带着贵宾犬的街上。所以，我必须相信我们——作为一个家庭——最终发挥的影响力比电视更强大，并且我们可以帮助D.J.优雅地适应迷恋女孩的阶段，就像他帮助我适应Stinker一样。
And if I can walk a poodle and not feel like a total fag, D.J. can go girl crazy one day and not be a total Zack. Or that's what I tell myself anyway when I'm walking D.J.'s poodle in the cruisy park late at night. I'm sure it's only a matter of time now before Stinker runs head first into a tree that has a bare-assed cop handcuffed to it. Thank you.
如果我能溜着贵宾犬而不觉得像个彻底的同性恋，D.J.有一天也可以去迷恋女孩而不用成为彻底的查克。或者至少，当我在深夜那个充满勾搭者的公园溜着D.J.的贵宾犬时，我就是这样告诉自己的。我敢肯定，现在Stinker一头撞到那棵铐着光屁股警察的树上只是时间问题。谢谢。
Dan Savage. He's the author of several books including The Commitment , including The Kid , What Happened After My Boyfriend and I Decided to Go Get Pregnant. He also writes the syndicated sex advice column, "Savage Love."
丹·萨维奇。他是几本书的作者，包括《The Commitment》，包括《The Kid》，以及《What Happened After My Boyfriend and I Decided to Go Get Pregnant》。他还撰写联合辛迪加的性建议专栏《Savage Love》。
Our show is produced today by Jane Feltes and our senior producer, Julie Snyder, with Alex Blumberg, Diane Cook, Sarah Koenig, Lisa Pollak, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Jeff [? Tober ?] runs our website. Production help from Seth Lind and Tommy Andres. Other help from Jorge Just.
我们今天的节目制作人是简·费尔特斯（Jane Feltes），资深制作人朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder），参与制作的还有亚历克斯·布隆伯格、黛安·库克、莎拉·柯尼希、丽莎·波拉克、阿莉莎·希普和南希·厄普代克。杰夫[? Tober ?]负责我们的网站。Seth Lind和Tommy Andres提供了制作帮助。Jorge Just也提供了其他帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Our show today, recorded in part in a live performance at Avery Fisher Hall at Lincoln Center for the Performing Arts in New York City, and in part in Boston, Los Angeles, Minneapolis, Chicago, and Seattle. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our show by our boss, Torey Malatia, who describes our staff this way.
今天我们的节目，部分是在纽约市林肯中心艾弗里·费雪厅进行现场表演录制的，部分是在波士顿、洛杉矶、明尼阿波利斯、芝加哥和西雅图录制的。《美国生活》由公共广播国际公司发行。我们节目由WBEZ管理监督，负责人是我们的老板托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia），他这样描述我们的员工。
We're well-meaning, lovable, unintentionally destructive, believing we're more important than we are.
我们是好意的、可爱的、无意中造成破坏的，相信自己比实际更重要。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助信用]
The new season of our show, This American Life , premieres Sunday, May 4 at 10:00 PM. 1-800-SHOWTIME or sho.com.
《美国生活》新一季节目将于5月4日星期日晚10点首播。1-800-SHOWTIME或sho.com。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。公共广播国际公司。